and sex assault accusations are serious
but can the current climate go too far
and when it's just an allegation just
enough to try to take a public figure
down my old boss Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas knows a thing or two
about that and so does my former guest
former presidential candidate I should
say Herman Cain speaking publicly for
the first time in this current climate
about the accusations that derailed his
bid for the White House in 2012
Herman it's great to see you first of
all welcome back to the to the network
this has been a wild time a lot of icons
in the media world one after the other
taken down a producer from State of the
Union on CNN it was unceremoniously
fired today for inappropriate conduct no
no no sexual attack or anything but
inappropriate conduct and the list goes
on and on what are your feelings about
this given the accusations against you
in 2012
well first Laura congratulations on your
new show thank you Ingram angle and now
you're gonna get the Kane critique on
the subject that you raised first of all
you can't look at all of these as the
same because they are not some of them
have evidence including pictures that it
actually happened some of them were
based upon accusations speculation but
no confirmation now I can't talk about
all these situations but I can talk
about my situation there were a lot of
accusations and that was a lot of
speculation to try to derail my campaign
but no confirmation and the reason was
the liberal media didn't want to know
the truth they did not want to know what
the facts were about the people that
were accusing me now what's different
about my situation and and that's to say
ROI moral situation is that they came
after me with repeatedly attacks in
accusations but no confirmation they now
believe that if they throw more and more
and more
on the wall that eventually people are
going to believe it but that is backfire
because as you know the latest poll
shows Roy Moore is now back in the lead
in Alabama and the people in Alabama are
gonna have to decide Herman you decided
to bow out in 2012 you had a you had a
really you know strong and vibrant
following and lot of people just liked
your presence in the race but when these
things started ping ping ping one after
the other coming out you just decided
for my family's sake I'm not gonna I'm
not going to continue do you regret that
now looking back do you wish you had
stayed in and fought it out no I do not
because as you pointed out they came
week 1 week 2 week 3 and what we
concluded was that it was going to
continue for five and six the way it did
with with the judge Roy Moore I bowed
out primarily because not because I
couldn't take the harassment I couldn't
take the firestorm but because my family
grandchildren especially start to hear
jokes about their papa on the music
stations and I did not want that to
continue if I had stayed in a race it
was only gonna get worse and worse and
worse why because the liberal media that
wanted to develop a firestorm to stop
somebody they were not going to stop and
I didn't want to continue to put my
family members at all levels in that
position I want to share something with
you that happened today apparently at
this Democratic caucus meeting and this
was involving the John Conyers situation
there's a push probably that looks like
to you know Buddha Mata Congress
encouraged him to resign james Clyburn
has compared John Conyers accusers to
the child murderer Susan Smith who
initially claimed a black man had
abducted her kids and cly Burton said
that these are all white women who've
made these charges against Conyers what
do you make of that outrageous claim
Larr who cares what color that skin is
all loving a cancer color has nothing to
do with it they are trying to deflect
the subject and to deflect the
accusations John Conyers is one of those
situations where there is absolute proof
that he did some of the things that he
did I mean you take senator Al Franken
you have a picture it shows that he did
some of the things that he was accused
of now you've got another situation
where is all accusations speculation
with no confirmation we got confirmation
with representative Conyers we got
confirmation with with Al Franken and we
got confirmation with Charlie Rose those
have confirmation and they have even
admitted it but you've got a lot of
others out there that are based on
accusations and speculation but no
confirmation what about this slush fund
Herrmann and and the House of
Representatives we're paying out
seventeen million dollars some of them
are not sexually related but apparently
none of these congressmen knew about it
and no one as far as I know and I've
interviewed in the house is demanding
that the names be released of who was
accused of what do you think that's
impressive yes it's important and I
believe that now that it has come to
light that representative de Canas used
that flood spawn and some of the things
that he wanted to cover up yes all right
the American people and the boaters and
the taxpayers deserve an explanation
we didn't even know that this lost
funding Herman none of these guys know
it's a total scandal and what else do
they not know that's my question
it's great to see you back thanks so
much for joining us